[Music]
some parents really struggle with like
all the other kids have the father
terrible thing so my kid has to yeah
let's let you know let your kid go and
be a better example to the kids they do
this just because the other stupid kids
have phones doesn't mean that okay well
my kid has to be stupid otherwise she'll
feel weird right you know I think these
things are toxic I don't especially for
kids it's just this thing it's bad I
mean yeah they don't look at people when
they talk to them and they don't build
the empathy
you know kids are mean and it's because
they're trying it out they they look at
a kid they go you're fat and then they
see the kids face scrunch up and they go
ooh that doesn't feel good to make a
person do that right but they got to
start with doing the mean thing but when
they write you're fat then they just go
mmm that was fun I like yeah exactly you
need the thing is I you need to build an
ability to just be yourself and not be
doing something that's what the phones
are taking away is the ability to just
sit there like this that's being a
person right yes
no one can they've got a you got a check
because they you know underneath
everything in your life there's that
thing that empty forever empty you know
what I'm talking about that's yes yes
yes yes yes knowledge that it solved for
nothing and you're alone you know it's
down there and sometimes when things
clear away you're not watching it you're
in your car and you start going oh here
comes that I am alone like it starts to
visit on you
you know just the sadness yes life is
tremendously sad just by you know being
in it and so you're driving and then you
go that's why we text and drive I look
around pretty much 100% of people
driving or texting yes and they're
killing everybody's murdering each other
with their cars yes but people are
willing to risk taking a life and
ruining their own cuz they don't want to
be alone for a second because it's so
hard I was in my car one time and a
Bruce Springsteen song comes on and it
made me really sad like jungle what the
one jungle jungle and this one where he
goes home
and he sounds far away that's half of
them
and it's really far away satting can you
do it with the reverb can you do yeah
they're not doing it yet so except for
it was Springsteen if it was you doing
that I would have been like the hell's
on my radio I did it just the same first
and I heard it and it gave me kind of
like a fall back to school depression
feeling made me really sad
yeah and I'm getting sad I've got to get
the phone and write high to like 50
people and then you know so many cool
writes back and then somebody not as
cool rights after and I'm like yeah hey
how come you didn't answer my texts
[Applause]
like his hero hero first so anyway I
started to get that sad feeling I was a
reaching for the phone then I said you
know what don't just be sad just let the
sad and just stand in the way of it and
let it hit you like a truck and I let it
come in bruised room and I just started
to feel oh my god and I pulled over and
I just cried like a [ __ ] I cried so
much and it was beautiful it was like
this beautiful is justice but sadness is
poetic you're you're lucky to live sad
moments and then I had happy feelings
cuz it cuz when you let yourself feel
sad yes your body has like antibodies it
has happiness that comes rushing in
rushing in to meet the sadness so you're
I was grateful to feel sad and then I
met it with true profound happiness it
was such a trip you know and the thing
is because we don't want that first bit
of sad yeah we push it away with like a
little phone third for the food and you
get you get a little kind of
you never feel completely sad or
completely happy
you just feel kind of satisfied with
your product yes and then you die so
that's why I don't want to get a phone
for my kids